what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so I don't normally do videos like this
I really leave this more to like
emergency awesome because that's kind of
his whole thing but Charlie I'm still
your format for today let me the whole
reason behind this is because of the
fact that the Logan film looks like it's
going to be amazing and I've had you
spots rattling around in my head for a
little while and so I figured I'd go
ahead and throw them out there but the
big question that I think everybody has
going into this movie is where are all
the music what happened all the reasons
because we know in the trailer at least
from a trailer we saw that from what
Wolverine says there's no more mutants
anymore and so the question is where did
they all go now this creates kind of an
interesting interesting scenario because
there's really only two possibilities at
least in my mind there's really only two
possibilities as to why they're both
equally possible but one's more
interesting than the other so to the
less interesting one to start that out
with it's really just kind of like a
statement made by Emma Frost in the
original old man Logan story Emma Frost
had made the statement that mutants were
just a blip on the radar that mutants
were not the future of humanity like
they weren't leading a new wave of
evolution it was just for a few
generations people were born with the X
gene with mutant powers and then nobody
was morally beaten powers after that now
that begs the question did this story
house of them happen in the old man
Logan universe of the Scarlet Witch
change reality and then set it back and
say no more mutants and then it was just
a permanent effect is that what happened
or within the context of the main story
from Marvel Comics House of them when
the skull of which major statement and
it's sort of shockwaves throughout the
multiverse was the old man Logan
universe one of the universes that was
affected and there were no more mutants
born just because of her actions
affecting the entirety of the multiverse
creature you know some really
interesting questions but that was
really what what happened you know in
the old man Logan story was just mutants
were a blip on the radar that was it and
there were no more mutants being born
going into the old man Logan story that
was not very interesting what is
interesting is the legacy virus and I
love the legacy virus concept but the
best way to think about it is that there
were three types of the legacy virus
there was legacy one two and three
legacy one was great storytelling legacy
two was a plot device and legacy three
was we got to wrap this up so when it
came to when I came to legacy really the
legacy virus itself
concept it was basically a Marvel comic
stand-in for like hiv/aids is really all
it was reminder 94 hiv/aids kind of
reach prominence in terms of the number
of people who are dying because of it
you know the social reaction to it I'm
not going to make this a political video
not at all
but comic books usually always try to
try to stay topical they always try to
engage themselves an ongoing themes and
the reason why is because it allows them
to tap into audiences that wouldn't
normally read their comics and so if the
hiv/aids pandemic is just kind of
creating this whole social storm this
whole of social upper work and then
suddenly Marvel Comics has something
called the legacy virus which is
basically the same thing as aids people
might be more inclined to read that and
so what's in the comic book lon hm sorry
legacy virus really appear at like the
very end of executioner's song an
executioner song with this 15 issue
story arc it was nuts that was
ridiculously convoluted and insanely
hard to understand it was one of those
really difficult stories to follow
because of the 1990 90s crossovers
weren't as easy to follow as they are
now Marvel just kind of threw out a
whole bunch of comics and was left on
you to put them in chronological order
about with regards to the legacy virus
what had happened is a villain named
stripe who was basically a clone of
cable from the future had traveled back
in time for the purpose of creating a
gene war and the idea was that sometimes
with some 2,000 years in the future the
villain apocalypse had taken over the
world but because of the fact that
apocalypse had this extreme social
social Darwin where he was like only the
strongest deserve to survive apocalypse
was working on a contagion that he would
spread into the atmosphere and that only
the strong would be able to survive the
weak their bodies would simply just
succumb to the illness and they would
die the problem was that apocalypse was
killed before the virus could be
finished and so strikes finished it off
came back to the present day and
released it on to the world now with
regards to what legacy did legacy 1 was
a fast-acting virus it was really the
the most comic book version of AIDS that
you could have seen at the time
basically what happened is that the
legacy virus was an airborne illness not
everyone contracted it but those who did
succumb to a really terrible set of
circumstances but only if they were
mutants if the a person contracted the
legacy virus the virus would go through
their entire genomes and if it did not
sense an X gene which is to say the gene
that gives me in 6 hours when the virus
would just die off but if it did pick up
a next gene if it did recognize the next
gene then the virus would kick in
and what it would do is it would place
basically a block the creation of new
and healthy cells because your body
creates you know new cells all the time
after old cells die off it's just the
natural function of your body it's just
how it works skin cells hair cells so on
and so forth what happens the legacy
virus is okay this person is a mutant so
basically when your cells die off no new
ones are being created and it basically
causes the body to break down on the on
the genetic level until the point that
you die and it happens extremely fast
one of the most notable ways to do this
was to kill the sister of Colossus
Illyana Rasputin now this listen also
allowed Marvel to kind of shake things
up of it because when Illyana Rasputin
died it was a huge deal and Marvel
Comics people were like oh my god like
Colossus sister died holy cow and even
then mother was able to write the story
of Colossus in a way that he was crushed
by the experience the problem was that
Marvel looked at the fan feedback to the
death of Colossus sister the subsequent
stories that they wrote and how well it
was received and said well we could do
something with this beyond just having
an incoming book adaptation of 8 and
that's what a plot device comes into
play and that's really where the legacy
virus just kind of meandered on for
almost a decade
what is up happening is Marvel initiated
the creation of something really kind of
a basically introduced something called
legacy 2 and what legacy 2 did was the
exact same thing as legacy 1 it would
block the creation of new cells the
difference is that along the way to your
eventual death your powers would flare
out of control now legacy 2 as was
written in Marvel Comics was the closest
to the intention of strife when he
released the virus in the first place he
wanted to basically start a gene war he
wanted to create a war between humans
and mutants where humans would be
terrified of mutants more so than they
were before and the reason why is
because of the fact that if legacy 2
caused mutants powers to spiral out of
control sin who knew what would happen
humanity would sit back and say well
what would happen if like some mutant
with telekinesis
you know that's infected with legacy -
yeah what happened they came walking up
to 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue lost control
of their powers and basically crushed
the entire White House so the entire
White House collapsing in on themselves
what would happen if some mutant with
the ability to control reality lost
control of their powers and destroyed
all existence maybe not necessarily on
that scale but what would happen if like
50 mutants were hanging out of them all
one day and they all lost their powers
the the loss of life would be insane not
to mention that is the property damage
and so on and so forth and so because of
that it basically reflected this normal
society view of you know the idea that
humans
and it amplified it even more because
now what started out as a fear of being
replaced by mutants turned into a fear
of being just wiped out by mutants that
couldn't control their power so it
allowed Marvel to sort of go through and
start you know messing things around and
adjusting a few things here and there
the problem is that in the midst of the
storytelling involving legacy to the
comic bust of the 1990s took place is so
comic sales just started tanking an
astronomical rate and so mod will
basically put legacy 2 on the backburner
and said we don't really have time to
flesh out this story we're just trying
to stay afloat we're just trying to keep
ourselves in business and so what
started out is a really really cool
concept it just became like a
reoccurring subplot and x-men lines of
stories now this basically went on for
quite some time but we did get some cool
stories out of it for example there was
a story where a villain named pyro
basically wanted to spend his last few
days being a good guy or historically he
was always a bad guy as it was kind of
cool to see these you know these these
mutants that were that were basically
bad guys trying to find some measure of
redemption it was kind of cool to see
those we also saw things like Jamie mad
rocks for years and years and years
Jamie mad rocks also known as multiple
man was believed to just kind of create
these multiple versions of himself and
that was it they were just replicas it
existed out there what the legacy virus
did is it allowed Marvel to come back
and say no no no they're not just you
know soulless replicas they're Jamie
madrix they have their own identities
they have their own views their own
perceptions they're effectively
individual people and so it was really
cool because we never looked at this
character like that before
now that helped to kind of rise the the
profile of multiple man for a little
while
the issue is that he still kind of
remained somewhat of an obscure
character but ones it up happening is
going into the early 2000s really into
2000 2001 Morrow was experiencing this
huge shake-up I mean we've talked about
this before we talked about Joe Quesada
coming on as editor in chief in my
recent video on the origin of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we talked about Ike
Perlmutter and avi arad coming on board
and restructuring Marvel from the ground
up so the idea was to basically wipe
away all those things that just didn't
really seem relevant anymore
we're basically just kind of taking up
space and the legacy virus was one of
those marbles sat down and said this
thing was introduced in 1993-94
it's just when hanging around ever since
and we've never done anything with it
and so what they did is they brought in
Chris Claremont along with a handful of
other writers is that your job is to
wrap up the legacy virus we
here how you do it just wrap it up and
so what we got was this sort of really
just kind of like a contrived story to
be quite honest what is up happening is
marble modify the legacy virus yet again
and gave us legacy three the difference
here is that legacy three function
almost identical to legacies one and two
but with the added benefit that it would
affect anybody who contracted it human
or mutant and so what this did is it
basically allowed marble to kind of hit
the panic button within their own
universe in the sense that well now if
the legacy virus can infect humans and
mutants well now we've got to hurry up
and we've got to find the cure for it
otherwise the entire population of
humanity will be wiped out and humans
will go extinct and so what ends up
happening is Marvel basically killed off
a character named Warmack tiger who had
really been a hold over for a couple
decades I mean her relevance in comic
books
vanished as soon as X been the animated
series came to an end no one cared about
her character and so because of that
Marv was like she's throw away we can
get rid of her she was the one that more
or less kind of laid the groundwork laid
the foundation for discovering a cure
the work that she had done was taken by
the x-men it was examined by beast but
because of the fact that Colossus had
defected from the x-men after the death
of his sister Ileana due to legacy one
and because the fact that he perceived
himself as making a few mistakes here
and there he more or less operated as a
martyr and so what Marvel did is they
had Colossus inject himself with the
cure for the legacy virus
he lost his life so then the virus turn
around and just wet when airborne and I
guess Sakura went airborne and spread
throughout the world curing everybody it
was half fought out and it was poorly
implemented but it achieved the goal
that Marvel was looking for they were
like now the legacy virus is gone now we
don't have to worry about it anymore and
that kind of set the stage for things
going after but that's really all it was
I mean in terms of the Logan film I
would say the legacy virus is a pretty
reasonable candidate for what's going on
the reason why is because if there's no
more mutants that are there we don't
know why we don't know if there's no
more mutants because they're dead we
don't know if there's no more mutants
because of the fact that they are not
popping up anymore we don't know if the
illness that Charles Xavier has is the
legacy virus and he's basically dying
because of it because remember as far as
we know the only two mutants that we're
seeing right now are Charles Xavier and
will reign now as far as I'm aware and
Marvel Comics
they never addressed Wolverines healing
factor in relation to the legacy virus
I'm not going to swear to that and if
you're really really familiar with the
legacy virus line of stories
post a comment down below and let me
know but I don't believe one will ever
square that circle and actually in the
animated series they did but in the
comics
I don't believe they did and so we could
easily look at this and say well Charlie
Xavier's not dying because these old
Charles Xavier is dying because he has
the legacy virus the legacy virus is
killing him
well rain doesn't contract it because
you've got a healing factor his body
just continually fights it off and
you'll be fine that would make a lot of
sense to be quite honest but I don't
know if that's exactly what's going on
in the film or not it could just be that
it's exactly what Emma Frost said and
the old man Logan story was just like
well mutants are a blip on the radar and
that's it you know and there's nothing
else to it other than that but if you
guys are new here to come into explain
and you guys enjoy this video make sure
you hit the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys want to see
more like this then make sure you drop
on like and make sure you guys go check
out emergency awesome too I mean I don't
really know if it's necessary for him to
get a shout out from his channel is
almost twice my size but it never hurts
to let people go check out other
youtubers and and be like hey go go
watch that guy's videos anyway guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end and it will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
yeah